welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and you just
rolled a Nat 20 on your history check of
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
because I'm about to break it all down
for you this movie is beyond jam-packed
with Easter eggs game mechanics and lore
so today I'm taking you frame by frame
through the movie to point out all the D
in details you might have missed get
suited up in all the gear you need for
your campaign by checking out all the
great merch at nerdriot.shop it's a
great way to support all the awesome
work we do here at new rockstars and to
look good while you're doing it find all
of our awesome merch options at
nerdriot.shop the movie opens up at
revel's end a prison built in the Frozen
far region of the Northwest on the
continent faerun this place holds only
the most serious and hardcore criminals
like Gorge the Hobgoblin and this Yanti
Abomination prisoner it's here that we
meet our heroes edgen Darvis and holga
Kilgore two prisoners brought before the
Absolution Council to appeal a pardon
for their crimes human counselor boss
anderton halfling Jill torbo and silver
Dragonborn krivnaryxius are all
characters introduced in the 5e module
will rhyme of the frost meeting while
Jonathan is an original character
created just for this movie Jonathan is
an era cochra a race of Birdman in true
d d fashion edkin introduces his
character in the same way that a player
would by giving us a long detailed
backstory including his racing class
edkin is a human Bard who used to be a
Harper in D lore the Harpers are a
scattered network of spies who advocate
for equality and oppose abusive power
during his time with the Harpers we see
Edgar trip against Yankee Thief with a
bride of frankenstein-esque streak of
white in their hair much like their 5e
monster manual depiction when edgin
finds his wife dying you can see that
the red wizards of fey left behind their
fabled blade you'll find this weapon in
a few other movie exclusive items as
well as stat blocks for the characters
published digitally as a promotional
tie-in they aren't a perfect one-to-one
to the film but they will help us
identify spells as we move through this
breakdown back to the flashback there's
a dragonfly at Zia's funeral as edgen
burns his Harper seal this animal
symbolically shows up every time edgen
thinks about Zia throughout the film
until he finally learns to let her
memory go edgkin met holga the human
barbarian from the elk tribe in a Tavern
the most common place for d d parties to
sync up polka's elk tribe can be found
in several DND materials and first
appeared in 1988 Savage Frontier
sourcebook Volga helped raise edgen's
daughter Kira and the three of them
along with their party Simon a sorcerer
Forge a rogue and sophina a wizard of
thay steal from the rich to survive
during one of their sprees Olga steals
an amulet of invisibility for Kira this
item is based on D D's ring of
invisibility which allows the player to
disappear until the ring is removed or
they attack in another Heist we see
Simon cast the spell fog Cloud he's also
equipped with a bag of holding a magical
sack that's bigger on the inside kind of
like a tardis this useful bag is why
Edgar repeatedly asked Simon to hold on
to items throughout the film
unfortunately their last mission went
horribly wrong determined to bring Zia
back from the dead the party broke into
a Harper's Hideout at corin's Key an
Island's stronghold in the sea of Swords
while Gorman's keep was made just for
the movie it's likely located in the
corn archipelago chain of islands found
west of the city of waterdi Peep the
Harper symbol on the doors they enter
edgen Strokes a magical cord on it to
get inside among the valuable items
inside Corn's keep wearing Alchemy jug a
container that can create and hold any
liquid the tablet of Reawakening and the
Horn of beckoning death in the chaos of
this scene I also saw what looks like a
blue cubic gate when Edgar fails a
perception check he trips the wire
attached to the tablet of Reawakening
alerting the Harpers at Corn's keep to
their thievery Sofina upcasts the spell
chain lightning to hit four targets she
then cast time stop a ninth level spell
that briefly stops the flow of time for
everyone but the Caster ninth level
spells are the highest level spells in d
d and can only be stopped by a ninth
level counter spell which explains why
Simon lacks the power in this moment to
stop her before the Absolution Council
can announce their ruling edgkin and
holga tackled Jonathan and forced him
out of the Hall of absolution's window
it turns out however that edgen
successfully rolled his Charisma check
with the council they were totally gonna
pardon him after listening to his
backstory this plays out like a table
not trusting a modest persuasion role of
like a 14 then jumping to plan B before
the DM can organically reveal their
success I love all the little moments
like this where we can feel the
characters rolling their ability checks
Edgar and holga right on Horseback past
Mount Houghton now a volcano in the
Crags mountain range next we see a
classic DND map that shows their Journey
on their way to the city of Neverwinter
when they arrive the Town Square is
decorated in banners displaying the
emblem of Neverwinter and the logo for
the heisen games although Lord never
Ember out a lot of the games three
decades ago he's in a coma now and Forge
fitzwilliams wants to party in DND Lord
Lord daggle never remember is the 15th
century ruler of Neverwinter who used
his family name and personal Fortune to
restore the city to its former glory
after briefly reuniting with Kira edkin
and holga learn that Forge is
manipulating Kira against her family
during their meeting Forge insists that
his tea is too hot and asks sophina to
cool it for him sofina's cold gross
thingy is one of the many uses of the
prestidigitation can trip which can
chill and flavor one cubic foot of
non-living material Forge informs them
that he intends to keep Edkins daughter
and have them sent back to prison and
Sofina traps the two adventures with the
spell transmute Rock to Mud this trap
also mirrors a scene in the 2000s
Dungeons and Dragons movie when Marlon
Wayans character snails get sucked into
a rug that turns to magical quicksand
Forge also mentions visitors from
waterdeep in Baldur's Gate two large
sister cities of Neverwinter that also
sit on the sword Coast as we transition
into the next scene we briefly see a
pair of rust monsters fighting over a
hunk of metal although forge's Officer
Blackwood tries to decapitate Edgar and
holgon sofina's discrete orders Olga
clearly rolls a series of nat 20s on her
Escape against Neverwinter guard and her
proficiency with impromptu Weaponry
shows that she's got the tavern
Brawler's feet she manages to steal
blackwood's dark steel grade ax which
was forged by gallerin gold hand foe
Hammer a shield dwarf master smith who
first appeared in 1993's volo's Guide to
the north dark steel itself is a hearty
material derived from the Starfall ore
of meteorites although edgkin finally
knocks Blackwood out with his loot it's
pretty clear that he did not roll very
well because he spends like 98 of the
encounter trying to break free of his
restraints after escaping tribor a
trading town to the west of Neverwinter
is actually their next stop there they
find Simon swindling an audience out of
their riches by distracting them with
lackluster sorcery like sophina Simon is
casting the cantrip prestidigitation to
light a small flame on his hand as well
as fill the area with the scent of
freshly cut grass fans of critical role
will note that this is is potentially a
subtle nod to fresh cut grass the name
of the aort Matan cleric played by Sam
Regal Simon also uses the Mage hand
Cantera likely invisible thanks to the
telekinetic feat to steal from the crowd
during his distraction he uses the minor
illusion can trip to make himself
slightly blurry and makes reference to
the second level spell blur as the
quote-unquote easier version of his
trick being a wild magic sorcerer Simon
has innate but unpredictable magic and
when he rolls poorly unexpected spells
are casts this is how he mistakenly
casts reverse gravity Simon is gagged
for a moment which prevents him from
casting magic as a number of spells
require verbal components Additionally
the movie makes several other spell
mechanic references including line of
sight and concentration d d and other
tabletop RPGs are a lot of fun but if
you're trying to play online there are
better ways to spend your time than
digging through forums and Discord
servers if you've never played before it
can be a lot especially when you really
just want it to start playing start
playing is a site with thousands of
games you can join right now without
having to do all the legwork of setting
up a game you can find your next game
group or game master on start playing
they make it easy for players to search
for games that fit their schedule you
can search by campaign or one shot type
of game system day and time you want to
play price vtt platform and even if a
campaign is brand new plus you can see
verified reviews on game Masters this
helps players find the right GM for
their play style me and Tommy's start
playing to find Claire who led Tommy's
gentle giant of a Bard and my
herringbone Rats on an adventure to win
a Wings eating contest at a local Tavern
okay rats is going to take several
chicken wings place them in Pip's hand
and then she's going to slip them
through the table crack so that pip has
been freed and has several Wings in his
hands I will have you make I suppose a
sleight of hand check oh 26
get out of there you could be in an
adventure of your own as soon as you
finish this video if you want to start
playing with start playing go to start
playing dot games if you're starting a
new account click the link in the
description of this video and you'll get
a 10 credit to make your first game even
easier as the thieves flee through a
field of green several ax beaks can be
seen their aggressive flightless birds
found in the D D monster manual Simon
leads the gang to Doric a tiefling druid
who is cast out of her human parents
home as an Abomination according to d d
lore although tieflings are human-born
they're infused with a touch of the
fiendish planes most often through
descent from fiends including devils and
demons with no home to return to Doric
joined the emerald Enclave a widespread
group of wilderness survivalists who
preserve the natural order rooting out
unnatural threats to save another member
of the emerald Enclave Doric hides in
the form of one of the guards horses
wild shaping into an owl bear just in
time to stop her friend from being
killed technically Charlotte's can't use
wild shape to transform into an owl bear
according to 5e rules but it's clear
that the director Masters John Francis
Daly and Jonathan Goldstein are down
with the rulaku while our adventures
nail down their plan in yet another
Tavern sastam appears in the shadows
back at Castle Neverwinter speaking to
sophina in d d lore sastam was a
powerful wizard of thay he was a part of
the Council of zulkers who each had
Mastery over a school of magic zastim
was the Lich master of necromancy and
this film gives us a closer look at his
Cannon COO of the nation of they
according to the credits the other
zulker he sneaks up behind is Dimitra
flas the Master of Illusions in modern
time zast ham is apparently the bbeg
pulling the strings behind Sophia's
actions to extend his influence over the
sword Coast to hide her loyalty to the
red Wizards sophina wears a cloak of
many fashions that can shift its
coloring Doric wild shapes into a fly to
spy on Forge sophina and forge's Wealthy
companions Caldwell imperatos as they
discuss their potential upcoming
winnings at the high Sun games Sofina
reveals that the door to the vault is
marked with Morden Cadence seal a spell
created by the archmage Morton Kaden
who's one of the strongest Wizards in d
d lore and the player character of The
Game's Creator Gary gygax this deal
mirrors the shape of Morgan kaiden's
staff and is unbreakable unless Our
Heroes can find the helmet of
Destruction interestingly the Helm of
disjunction was inspired by another of
Morden Kaiden spells Morden kaiden's
disjunction this spell reduces magical
items to their most basic counterparts
effectively canceling them doric's
Escape has her breaking wild shape rules
once more casting it seven times in one
day to become a fly a mouse twice a
falcon a cat an ax speak and finally a
deer chasing her Sofina casts Misty step
to teleport and what looks to be her
version of melf's minute meteors for
projectiles
minute man I turn small think
you after briefly stopping by her
ex-husband's house halfling Bradley
Cooper AKA Marlin polka learns that he
has a type human barbarians his new wife
Gwen mentioned squashing a pack of bully
wugs frogmen from d d lore holga takes
Marlin's walking stick back and later
Simon rules a better Arcana check to
identify it as a hither thither staff an
ancient Relic created for Honor among
Thieves at the elk tribe's burial ground
North in the evermores Simon uses his
deathly token to cast the spell speak
with dead this deathly token features
the symbol of killum for aka the lord of
the dead and the judge of the Damned
above the heroes in this scene are the
tears of saloon an asteroid cluster that
orbits the world of torrel alongside the
moon both the moon and the tears are
named after Moon Goddess Saloon a
handful of movie original corpses
recount their battle Tales recalling the
black dragon rayquar that the cult of
the Dragon commanded to attack the
evermores The Cult of the Dragon has
been around since 2nd edition but raycor
was created just for Honor among Thieves
that said black dragons are the meanest
dragons in d d lore and spew acid breath
when questioning the last corpse Edgar
asks for his favorite book and he
mentions the thing Tome of lichenthus a
rare magical book that appears in the
2006 novel black staff the Dead Guy
leads them to Zhang who clearly has an
equally tragic backstory to edkin as a
child he witnessed SAS Tam's coup
firsthand watching helplessly is the
most powerful necromantic Lich use the
Horn of beckoning death to transform his
loved ones into Undead Warriors sastam
say generals cast a wall of force to
hold their victims in place while
becoming Undead zenk dedicated his life
to becoming a Harper vowing to keep the
helmet of disjunction safe from harm
zenk is also a paladin a DND class that
swears to uphold an oath of
righteousness his resume according to
the party includes fighting the evil
clerics of storm God Talos aiding
holga's cousin in the great sansi and
rumor has it that he even fought a
Beholder once one of D D's most iconic
and deadly monsters in the village west
of The evermores morbin's Shield zenk
saves a baby to baxi AKA a cat person
from being eaten by an enormous fish to
do this he casts the spell animal
friendship he then stops to help out a
down on their left Dragonborn we also
get a quick look at the long tongues of
a giant clam here after joining up with
zinc the party passes a giant spider and
drops down into an orifice located in
Crypt Garden Forest to access the
underdark Simon volunteers to go last
this is a subtle nod to marching orders
the way that players decide the order in
which their characters travel the
underdark itself is a vast network of
underground tunnels and caverns that
Lies Beneath faerun home to countless
horrifying monsters creatures and
unpleasant enemies the underdark is
extremely dangerous to travel through in
part due to its lack of lighting the
only light that exists in the underdark
comes from glowing fungi which can be
seen briefly as our heroes pass by the
hanging city of Dahl blend in D lore
doll blend is an abandoned gnomish city
and home to dowagatha a fearsome
dracolich along this passageway the
party encounters several intellect
devourers monsters from DND lore that
consume a creature's mind and memories
forcing its own to become a puppet under
its control as Servants of the Mind
flayer these walking brains are
incredibly deadly to players with high
intelligence here's another little d d
inside joke zenk explaining the
extremely intricate puzzle they need to
solve in order to cross the bridge has
exactly the same energy of a passionate
excited DM but like a lot of players
Simon cuts off zinc's long ass list of
well-thought-out instructions by
accidentally tripping the mechanism to
collapse the bridge check out those
statues surrounding zank and drawless
during their fight sculpted in the image
of the underdark dwelling dwarves of the
same name Indian D lore ethradralis is a
powerful female red lizard if they and
one of zastam's most loyal followers in
honor among Thieves drawless is one of
zastam's Undead Warrior assassins
converted and transformed along with
seng's people during the coup as a
paladin thanks Divine sense alerts him
to drawless and his Undead Warriors
danger before they strike drawless uses
the cantrip green flame blade in battle
but although Zhang temporarily defeats
him drawless and the other thay
assassins pop back up like zombie
daisies due to their inability to fully
die zank also enchants his weapon with a
Smite spell like blinding Smite but
because he doesn't hit trellis before
he's disarmed it doesn't do much help
but even Undead red Wizards can't escape
the mighty and tubby fember child a red
dragon from d d lore who used his fire
breath to light the forges of the gray
dwarves of gracklesta in exchange a
group of psionic duragar priests obeyed
his every whim bringing him treasure and
a bottomless all-you-can-eat people
Buffet to snack on my favorite part of
the whole movie is when he just rolls
around like a pug snacking on Wizards I
know he's a baddie but I would die for
this hungry chunky baby let him eat me
it would be so cute here's a couple fun
little d d moments as the group realizes
that they're about to run into a dead
end with member Chow's gaping ma hot on
their tails dork does the movie
equivalent of rolling a perception check
to find a means of Escape gym Master
rolled highest because she's the one who
spots the raised platform that Simon
portals them up to then birds out also
can't repeatedly use his breath weapon
in this scene because he has to wait for
it to recharge I also love that zank
leaves the party after completing this
Dungeon Crawl it feels just like the
moment your older brother's buddy has to
get back home for dinner after doing a
guest spot in your home campaign when
Simon attempts to attune to the helm for
the first time he's greeted in what
appears to be the astral plane by his
great great grandfather L Minster Omar
as one of the most powerful spellcasters
in existence Omar learned every common
spell in the Realms gaining psionic
powers and the abilities to heal himself
and shape-shift when playing d d a
character has to spend a short rest
attuning to a new magic item before its
magical properties can be used which is
essentially what Simon does while the
crew takes a snooze in another move
straight out of your home d d game the
party gets creative during the big
Carriage Heist of the film there's so
many dice rolls you can feel here
including the failed perception checks
from the DM side of the table after
their success Simon pulls sending stones
out of his bag of holding telling the
party that they'll only work as
walkie-talkies for an hour according to
DND lore sending stones communication
over vast distances these little babies
even get good reception across other
planes of existence during Edkins bardic
inspiring speech to Rally Simon he
mentions a time in the city of loudwater
where he could only cast the spell
spider climb after being attacked by
joylam's dogs edgkin also reminds him of
the time where the party was robbing the
Spear of a pheasant a than Warrior and
Simon was able to Cast Stone skin more
fun DND Shenanigans Simon clearly does a
terrible role as they try to distract
the Neverwinter guards which causes the
illusion he casts of Edgar playing the
loot to malfunction it dissipates once
touched just like in the game also one
of the guards mentions the nine Hells in
this scene home playing to lawful evil
beings and Devils each of the deadly
nine house reflects a different
malevolent characteristic of its ruler
at this point in the adventure each
character begins to perform their
individual contributing tasks working
together to gain access to forge's
treasure Vault to steal the tablet of
Reawakening obviously this is also
Classic Fair for a game of d d each
member of the party has to roll to
advance on their specific missions in
order to help the whole team the DM even
levels up holga's favorite weapon during
her scene Simon upon attuning to his
helmet casts out a wave of magic that
disables magical items including the
seal and a series of floating drift
Globes after the whole party is trapped
by the spell everard's black tentacles
edkin rolls Charisma to convince Forge
to let them compete in the heisen games
during the competition the gang runs
into another party straight out of the
80s Dungeons and Dragons cartoon Hank
the ranger Erica Cavalier Diana the
acrobat Presto the magician Sheila the
thief and Bobby the Barbarian and all be
seen in their brightly colored costumes
during the sequence inside the maze
heisen gamers are faced with deadly
creatures and items such as the
displacer Beast a mimic and a gelatinous
cube displacer beasts or large predatory
cat-like creatures equipped with two
deadly tentacles sprouting from their
shoulders they use their ability to bend
light to make themselves appear a few
feet away from where they actually are
we see this effect in full force when
the display service takes out a dwarf in
the maze holga almost gets got by a
minute a monster with the ability to
disguise itself as an inanimate object
most commonly a chest in order to get
the jump on their victims gelatinous
cubes are also extremely deadly
engulfing their victims and dissolving
them in acid and their escape from Forge
Simon casts control water to push the
boat out to sea but once they see that
Sofina has started the beckoning death
they sail back into the city on the
outside of the arena there are two
statues of Lord nashar alagandar a
former Adventurer and ruler of
Neverwinter and Lord halulath never one
of the early founders of Neverwinter
Indian dealer as our adventures fight
sophina we see a ton of really cool
spells cast first Sofina casts Fireballs
in meteor swarm on the party luckily
Simon casts a shielding spell that
protects them from the blast but he
can't stop sophina from bringing the
stone statue of a copper Dragon to life
in the town square with animate objects
although copper dragons are usually
pretty drovial in nature according to D
lore they are known to get greedy and
vicious when their treasure hordes are
threatened this parallels the fact that
4 George just lost his entire supply of
riches because animate object requires
concentration Doric is able to stop the
dragon by hitting Sofina with her sling
sophina fights Simon using big B's hand
and he counters with maximilian's
Earthen grasp after an epic beat down
that embodies the game's round of combat
as six seconds of continuous action
sophina casts yet another time stop
spell but unlike last time Simon is now
a high enough level to counter it with
his own magic here is able to prove
herself as a sleight of hand Rogue and
places a magic restraining cuff on
sophina's wrist just before she's able
to cast The Deadly spell finger of death
after holga dies by sofina's Red
Wizard's blade Edkins sees his wife's
dragonfly for the last time and he and
Kira decide to use the stone of
Reawakening to bring holga back as they
celebrate their win Simon reminds them
that sastam won't be happy that they
defeated his most loyal supporter
setting up the possibility of future
sequels involving this big bad villain
Forge is brought to Justice when zank
finds him crawling through the Crypt
Garden Woods in the same exact place
where he found the Evermore soldier who
died trying to protect the Helm of
disjunction as Forge begs for a pardon
at revel's end he tries to present the
council with his own tragic backstory it
turns out that when holga called Forge a
son of a earlier and zank asked if
his dastardly ways were due to his
matriarchal upbringing they were right
these are all the Easter eggs and
details that I could find in d d honor
among Thieves but I want to know what I
missed in the comments follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you